Miles
Miles!
You got a minute?
Gwen? How did you get how have you been it's a long
story is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adult right no of
course hey are these your drawings what no no good
i missed you too okay so what are
you doing here i mean i i thought i'd
never see you again want to
get out of here i'm grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded um i mean
Welcome back everyone this will be my new
spider-man into the spider-verse 2 trailer video
spider-man across the spider-verse is now the
confirmed title there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs here and i'll explain what's going on with
the whole part one of it all like part one of two
they're doing like an avengers endgame avengers
infinity war situation where it's basically two
movies but it's kind of like one big story spread
out we're doing a ticket giveaway for spider-man
no way home all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite moment from
this trailer in the comments so i'll just start
at the beginning of the trailer and work our way
through shot by shot talking about easter eggs
as we go along but the whole idea is that you see
miles morales going across the spider verse across
the multiverse it's called the spider verse but
it's a different way of looking at the multiverse
so it's the same basic concept in the first movie
it was all these different versions of spider-man
from different universes coming to miles morales
universe ultimate spider-man's universe but
this time it's miles morales going to different
universes himself but they opened the trailer
the same way they did the opening credits for
the first movie with that record scratch moment
where the beat stops really quickly and you kind
of expect to hear someone say here we go one last
time again all right let's do this one last time
but the opening scene is basically that ending
scene from the first movie where miles morales
is sitting in his bed listening to the post malone
song and then looking up at the ceiling as another
portal opens up and you hear spider gwen's voice
hailee steinfeld if you guys didn't realize it
was hayley steinfeld who played spider gwen and
she's also playing kate bishop in the live-action
hawkeye series right now so she's kind of blowing
it up all over the marvel universe right now
but this trailer basically confirms a lot of our
theories about what was going on during that scene
the spider-man into the spider-verse post-credits
scene confirmed that a version of spider-man 2099
in the future in the year 2099 played by oscar
isaac no less he's going to be playing moon
night in the live-action mcu series next year had
created the webware wrist watches from the comics
that allows them to go across the spider-verse at
will like they can do it when they want to now so
the theory was that the spider-gwen had gotten one
of those wrist watches from spider-man 2099 so it
just sounds like she got help from spider-man 2099
in opening the portal to miles morales universe
again but she's basically surprising him him
thinking that he would never see her again like
they had that awkward funny moment because they
were kind of teasing a romance between the two of
those characters a little bit we'll see a little
more of that continue through these next two
movies they say this is part one so i'm assuming
that there's a two-part story but they'll probably
keep doing these sequels as long as people
keep paying to go see the movies so hopefully
they'll do many more than two the strange tales
spider-man comic book that's floating around him
with his version of spider-man on the cover is
meant to represent the plot of the first movie
but it's like saying that there's an in-universe
comic book that's basically a spider-verse
storyline comic book like marvel comics real life
line of spider-man into the spider-verse comics
but in this context it's just meant to be a
clever wink about the plot of the first movie
the other big difference is that when she
portals into his universe the portals themselves
look a little bit different so i think they just
tuned those up like they're just saying that
oh these are different because of the way that
spider-man 2099 engineered his technology allowing
him to open portals at will if you look around his
bedroom you can just see a lot of his childhood
toys it's just meant to look exactly like it
looked during the first movie she teases him a
little bit looks at some of his drawings remember
he was drawing during the beginning of the first
movie but they kind of put that on hold because
he was so busy becoming spider-man and learning
the ropes and what was going on with the kingpins
plot trying to stop him so he just gone back to
drawing in the time since the first movie ended
but you have to remember that no time has passed
between that ending scene and what's happening
right here in this scene here so it's almost
like he goes back to his house then sits down
gets grounded within like a couple moments she
shows up in another portal like very little time
has passed since kingpin was arrested then she
teases him again and then gets him to come out
and have some fun with her around the city but
i think the idea is that she's going to tell him
about what's going on with spider-man 2099 in this
larger threat that's going to cause him to have
to go across different universes that's one of the
few things that they don't really tell you about
this trailer like why is it that he does need to
go across universes is this going to be inheritor
storyline is it going to be something from the
spider-verse comics but then they show you him
traveling through spider-man 2099's portals
through a bunch of different universes notice the
very cosmic-looking webbing connecting different
universes in the background here that's just a
visualization of the spider-verse is a certain way
of visualizing the connections between universes
that only certain people can see that way madame
webb being one of those characters so maybe we
will see a version of madame webb at some point
during this too but it sounds like spider-man 2099
is driving a lot of this plot during the trailer
here if it wasn't clear the first world that he
travels to if i'm not mistaken i believe this is
indian or hindu writing in the background here
somebody can confirm here like this is a world
where the entire world is much more influenced
by hindi culture then spider-man 2099 comes
out of another one of his portals catches him
and takes him to the next universe and if you
couldn't tell from the writing in the background
there's a mixture of spanish and english writing
it's meant to be nueva york the designation on his
wristwatch says universe 928 that's the universe
where spider-man 2099 comes from so he's taking
miles morales to his original universe because
there's probably some threat in his universe we
knew they would include him somehow but i wasn't
expecting him to be like the main character but
don't worry they did tease that peter b parker
would be coming back too so most of the characters
from the first movie will be coming back that was
what that first teaser trailer was for where they
cycled with all the different spider-man logos
all the different versions of spider-man that they
would feature during the movie then the logo at
the end if you couldn't tell is miles morales new
logo that you see on his costume so it's like a
slightly more refined looking version of the logo
that he spray painted on during the first movie i
think this is just meant to imply that he gets a
slight costume upgrade because with enough wear
and tear the spray paint probably wouldn't last so
it's probably just a slight costume upgrade where
the logo just gets polished a little bit more but
it's basically his version of the logo all these
glitches when they reveal the title spider-man
across the spider-verse is just them showing you
some of those logos just in a slightly different
way than they did during the first teaser trailer
i'm not totally sure why they decided to do it as
a part one maybe the story that they were doing
just seemed so big like an avengers infinity war
type of story that they wanted to break it into
two movies so what they might do between the
release of part one and part two is they might
do the avengers end game thing where instead of
calling it infinity war part two they called it
avengers end game changing the title so instead
of spider-man across the spider-verse part 2 they
might just call spider-man into the spider-verse 3
some other subtitle but what i'm hoping that they
try with this movie that they didn't wind up doing
in the first movie is they said they actually
planned because they did so many crazy versions
of spider-man they had actually talked about
doing legit live-action inserts with versions
of tom hall and spider-man at one point i was
supposed to be in it yeah there was going to be
another peter parker like it was like a scene
in a train station or something and like it was it
was gonna be like a like an easter egg i was gonna
walk through the background and say like hey kid
or something and never happened i'm heartbroken um
but i'm just excited for us to introduce miles
into our own universe one day i think that's
going to be really cool should be wild they
talked about bringing tobey maguire and andrew
garfield back and now that we have spider-man no
way home happening and they really are kind of
doing a version of live-action spider-man into
the spider-verse with three different versions
of spider-man in a bunch of their sinister six
villains from each universe hopefully sony will
double down and say okay you know this time we're
going to let you do that we'll get tom holland to
have a cameo scene in some way or mcu spider-man
in some way and we'll get tobey maguire we'll get
andrew garfield to do cameos they said the reason
why they didn't do that during the first movie is
because sony at the time remember this is 2018
when the movie dropped they said that it was
too soon to bring tobey maguire and andrew
garfield back and do tom hank crossover with the
live action movies like at that time they thought
that it was too weird to do something like that
now in 2021 we're in like a hold my beer situation
with spider-man no way home with all the craziness
that they're doing in live action clearly they are
totally okay with doing crazy stuff like that now
the only other version of spider-man that they've
absolutely confirmed like legit on their twitter
was spider-man the japanese spider-man from
his tv show with his giant mech so we'll see
a version of him during the movie i did a couple
several videos for the teaser where they teased
all the other versions of spider-man the brand
new ones with the different logos so i'll have
links with that down in the description below
if you haven't seen those do you know peter
parker who's spider-man yes is that him no
is that him no is that him no is that him no
is that him no is that him yes it's been a hot
minute since they teased anything for this movie
so i think they're just trying to capitalize on
all the hype around spider-man no way home they're
also doing an animated disney plus spider-man
tv show with tom holland's mcu spider-man but
that's not going to happen for a couple more
years that's called spider-man freshman year
i did a whole separate video about that i believe
they also dropped a brand new morbius trailer so
i'll do a video for that tomorrow too there's just
a lot of spider-man stuff happening right now so
it's all really cool don't worry i will do videos
for everything if you spotted any cool easter
eggs in this trailer that i didn't talk about in
the video just write them below in the comments
but there'll be another trailer for this sometime
early next year or by next summer at least
while you wait for everything click here for my
brand new spider-man no way home trailer video
and click here for all those other spider-man
into the spider-verse 2 teaser trailer videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!